You're looking at the new thing in toys.
Not really the tanks themselves, but how they're being controlled by smartphones.
Right now here,...
...the global market trend is to integrate technology and electronics with toys...
...in order to explore more playing possibilities.
And at this fair in Hong Kong, it's the smarter toys that are drawing the attention.
That includes this toy gun that has an iPhone attached to it.
We see the potential of augmented reality...
...and we thought this technology will enhance the toy's playing level...
...or enhance the game of the toy.
Traditionalist, be not afraid.
Despite all of these high-tech gadgets,...
...the fair was still dominated by stuffed animals,...
...regular remote-controlled cars and helicopters,...
...and of course, the little plush toys for babies.
John Belmont, Associated Press.